so this is so much fun yeah it's such a
great time it's great and I'll text you
yeah yeah I'll do all right yeah oh
you're leaving yeah I gotta get ready
for work but maybe we can get lunch
sometime soon yeah I'll be good
I'm a big cannolis right let's do it
oh you're an emeritus I'm having a
really good time me too
[Music]
[Music]
something's happening I'm thinking
fettuccine alfredo I can't explain it
I'm starting to worry should I call the
police
no what you're crazy I'm sure he's just
busy look we put this picture on
Instagram last night and now he's gone
from it how do you explain that
maybe you just chose a bad filter I
thought everything was going great was
it something I did was it something
about me not chief me I thought I was
alone
oh it's been happening for years this is
the first coaster oh my god this must go
back further than we thought
price-wise come look at this breaking
news right now
it's called ghosting and it's a new
affliction sweeping the nation people in
their 20s and large cities have been the
primary targets oh my god
hey where were you this weekend why
didn't you return my calls so um I was
camping I thought I told you you're not
gonna like ghost on me are you no of
course not all right let's take a
picture for Seth
check this out this place book is
deactivated maybe block you wait he
liked my status but he can't respond to
my text what am I supposed to do now go
to the movies alone I've already bought
the ticket nothing makes it easy
what do you mean to just vanish that's
impossible I know what I saw why would
you believe you're crazy what if this is
all happening because people are afraid
of commitment and confrontation you know
I've been on a couple dates with this
girl but I'm just not really feeling it
Oh God
[Music]
it's the only reasonable explanation why
she hasn't called me back yeah dude
you're probably right